hey I'm TI with kiik we're both three
and a half out of five maybe I'll play
him next game that'd be exciting I've
never played him
before it's one of my New Year's
resolutions it's to play Vladimir Kik
he's probably one of the strongest
players I've never played
before so I've played like I've played
Magnus hakaru Fabby fuja never played
vishy vishy usually doesn't play title
ches oh playing Vincent kimer well I'm
playing V K but it's not quite Vladimir
kiik actually probably a stronger
version of
VK A3 of
course
okay let's play a London reverse
London oh this is already probably
better for
yeah can I just can I Gambit though like
this
just gamut the
pawn we'll see how badly Vincent wants
to take a free
[Music]
Pawn isn't there a song
Vincent who's it by Don
mlan I should not be thinking of that
right now let's just
develop so I gamiing against super
GM can
take uh
oh huh Bishop
D6 problem is Knight C3 could play Rook
B8 Rook B8 first
idea Rook
B6 I mean I have simple moves coming
up White's a bit
underdeveloped Bishop tied down to the B
Pawn by The Rook
could start with a rook
[Music]
B6 yeah Queen A4 probably
coming thank you Jack the
[Music]
noble
preparing C5 not allowing the fork
Knight C6 Queen
A8
Bishop
C5
just Queen E7 if Bishop
[Music]
G2
there
that's
let's go let's
go a weird Gambit paid
off A3 was kind of a troll opening but
reverse London
Gambit
okay my best win of the year so
far the year just
began and the goal is still to play
karnick but um have to wait for that I
mean I think here I was a bit more
scared of Knight D4 and then Knight
C6 what was my Peak heart rate that game
they really get to
168 I definitely felt the
the
Jitters trying to stay calm
though oh yeah sorry staring
Knight okay let's see how how dubious
was this
Gambit yeah like once we got to this
position I I already regretted choosing
this opening because A3 is like a very
useful move in preventing this idea if
the pawn is still on A2 then they can
play Knight A6 and uh Queen B7 Knight B4
but here yeah I just had to go for the
Gambit
um oh I guess Knight
D5 ah Knight okay so Knight D4 I have
Knight
C5 and then white doesn't have time to
do this or this so I'm attacking the
queen and then this runs into this which
traps a queen a nice Queen
trap
so Black's already for Choice
here engine just says it's
equal but maybe I mean in a few moves it
just became easier to play for
black a bit more
development I was happy with this too
just not getting forked and preparing
C5 and white never really completed
development in this
game
yeah Knight B3 wow Knight takes D3 was
best
E3 okay apparently there's massive
counterplay Knight B3 is still better
for
black and then yeah White's position
kind of crumbled around
here if Queen B2 I wasn't entirely sure
what I was going to
play apparently the only winning move is
a
take and C3
also not sure if I would have found this
takes takes and
then Queen E4 hitting the Knight and
Rook Hey Alyssa how's it going thanks
for
raing if you're just joining I just had
a a nice upset win over one of the top
players in the world Vincent kimer